this week on brian ross investigates
locked up
american lawyer steve donziker went to
the amazon to help people there fight
against a giant oil company the whole
idea of this case was to go into court
and use the rule of law to get justice
for people who've been wronged who've
been had their lands polluted by chevron
but now donziger is in an american
prison convicted of contempt of court
after refusing to turn over his files to
the oil company
judge kaplan's order was so broad that
chevron would have gotten access to all
kinds of privileged information
sensitive information
it would have put the lives of my
clients i believe in danger
imprisonment has sparked outrage around
the world and we'll talk with his lawyer
about what happens next
plus the torture tales for the first
time one of the detainees at guantanamo
has testified in public about the
torture inflicted on him by the cia
it's the first time anybody has publicly
heard a description of the torture
i mean so that itself is a breakthrough
his sense of genuine sense of remorse
the vulnerability the horror of the
torture that he went through so that is
what surprised me
and this week's winners and losers in
the media see if you agree with the
choices made by the editors of mediaite
basically we need to stop being dicks
and assuming that the unhoused are a
collection of drug addicts criminals
who've chosen this life for themselves
from the law and crime trial network
this is dragon rost investigates
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our friends on
facebook live i'm brian ross joined as
always by my colleague here at law and
crime rhonda schwartz and rhonda we
begin with the story of an american
lawyer stephen donzager who tonight is
in prison
as a result of his efforts to help the
people in the jungles of south america
fight against a giant oil company they
say destroyed their lands rhonda
that's right brian a federal judge here
in new york said donzinger thumbed his
nose at the judicial system in refusing
to turn over his files and computers
sought by chevron but his imprisonment
has sparked international outrage with a
u.n human rights group saying that u.s
courts should not have sent him to
prison
we're joined now by ron kuby the new
york lawyer who represented steve
donsacker stephen dunsager mr kuby thank
you for being here let me ask you for
the beginning how long will he be behind
bars and are there any legal steps
remaining to get him out
he was sentenced to six months he served
a little over a week of that so he has
another
170 or so days to remain in uh danbury
federal prison until he's released are
there any views left for that
there are his appeal is going to be
heard by the second circuit court of
appeals on november 30th
they'll make a decision you know in in
their own good time uh but he will have
served a substantial chunk of his
sentence before the legality of the
prosecution uh is is ever determined by
an appeals court we have requested
free on bail pending appeal
uh the district judge ruled that he was
such a flight risk he had a surrender
within 24 hours
of the second circuit denying his bail
application and of course there was the
irony of the flight risk driving himself
to prison as he did last week and the
only reason he had to go to prison was
because the judge said he was a flight
risk
and you've talked to him how are his
spirits locked up behind bars
his spirits are good
uh you know steve is remarkably
resilient he wouldn't have been able to
fight you know chevron and and its
corporatist tools for as long as he had
without being resilient a jail is
obviously a new experience for him but
he's not in camp fed here
uh he's in a low security institution
which you know mostly means the
other prisoners are are all there for
non-violent defenses but some of them
are serving uh very long sentences uh
he's in dormitory style housing there's
59 people crammed together in one room
people doing their laundry and hanging
laundry on the pipes and and steven said
it actually looked like some of the
refugee camps that he visited and now
he's a a part of
a question for you ron cooby from rhonda
schwartz rhonda
so chevron says that your client is a
disbarred lawyer
and that u.s courts threw out the
original judgment against them saying it
was obtained by fraud and bribery
so what do you say to them
i i say that that decision about fraud
and bribery was made by one
district court judge
judge kaplan
not by a jury and stephen wanted the
jury chevron decided it did not want a
jury
judge kaplan uh it's hard to know
whether he was hand-picked by chevron
from the beginning or or simply chevron
through his lawyers
later got the case sent to him once it
came to him he hung onto it like a
remora on a shark
stayed with it for a decade and then
brought these criminal contempt charges
against stephen donziger so if chevron
actually had a colorable case of fraud
they should have tried it to a jury
let me follow up on that in a moment but
first let's take a look at one of the
last interviews mr donziger did before
going to prison talking about the scare
at brian ross investigates
judge gave you the maximum sentence she
said you showed an astonishing lack of
respect for the law and that you had
been thumbing your nose she said at the
judicial system for the last seven years
and she said now it's time to pay the
piper what do you say
it's just not true um you know
from my perspective uh i have
complied with the rule of law
consistently for the last 30 years
fighting for the ecuadorian indigenous
peoples i mean the whole idea of this
case was to go into court and use the
rule of law to get justice for people
who've been wronged who've been had
their lands polluted by chevron
you know what actually happened back in
u.s courts after the ecuadorian courts
won
is judge kaplan who who appointed judge
prescott
issued a series of rulings that i
challenged
i did what lawyers do i appealed orders
i filed motions and what judge prescott
did on friday was shocking to me because
she interpreted every single one of
those challenges to his orders as
disobedience to the rule of law this
grew out of reportedly your refusal to
turn over certain electronic devices
notes documents to chevron so they could
further sue you why didn't you turn them
over
thank you for asking that i mean that
really is the graviment of the dispute
related to my detention you know
basically what happened was in my
computer are all sorts of privileged
documents and information communications
with my clients communications with
other attorneys and i've never said i
won't turn over my computer under a
valid court order
judge kaplan's order was so broad that
chevron would have gotten access to all
kinds of privileged information
sensitive information
it would have put the lives of my
clients i believe in danger because they
would have gotten all their personal
data people down in ecuador i'm talking
about
so i appealed the order of judge kaplan
and while i was appealing the lawfulness
of his order he charged you with
criminal contempt of court for not
complying with the order i was appealing
mr danziger you spent the last two years
under house arrest you've been disbarred
in new york state as a lawyer you're now
facing six months in prison but as your
friends say you keep smiling
you know
i can't really explain that i
am proud of the accomplishments of the
people of ecuador i've i i you know this
case is viable you know a lot of people
say oh you lost you're in prison your
life must be miserable and of course
it's terrible to be locked up but the
reality is this is happening brian in my
view because we've been successful in
other words the this is an historic
achievement that indigenous peoples won
a large pollution judgment against a
major u.s oil company and the damage
down there is undisputed it's terrible
people are still suffering so the fact
that that accomplishment has happened
gives me great satisfaction are you
prepared to spend six months in prison
i don't want to go to prison i want to
continue my work i think i've spent
enough time
detained in my home over two years for a
misdemeanor four times longer than the
maximum sentence
um but if if i have to go to prison
obviously i'll go and i'll do the best i
can with it
so mr coomie let me ask you if he
continues to refuse to turn over those
files could there be more charges
against him could he be back in prison
well that's that's an excellent question
brian and the answer is no one really
knows
i i mean at this point i mean chevron
won their case in 2017 it was over
instead of just being a good winner and
taking the win okay you got a judge who
ruled in your favor uh you won
congratulations instead of taking the
win they went after stephen personally
uh on these sort of collateral matters
that had nothing ultimately to do with
the merits or demerits of the underlying
case
and in the process
of of bullying him and burying him under
all these these documents and demands in
various this jenga style tower of court
orders um
stephen created a movement around
himself and around his case people
started to take notice and i think
ultimately this is all backfired on
chevron i mean they have created a
martyr among us that they didn't have to
create just because they couldn't take
the win because they're so used to
operating with utter impunity ron kuby
thank you so much for joining us tonight
i hope you'll come back with your client
once he's released from prison
as soon as i can fetch him brian i will
coming up next the torture tales for the
first time one of the men tortured by
the c.i.a in the so-called war on terror
speaks publicly about what he went
through you're watching brian ross
investigates on the law and crime trial
network
it was the video that shocked the nation
an unarmed black jogger 25 year old
ahmad abre gunned down in broad daylight
the three men charge will now stand
trial for live galado gabo coverage of
the trial subscribe to law and crime on
youtube tv today
for the first time one of the men
tortured by the c.i.a in the wake of the
9 11 attacks has testified publicly
about what he went through in those
notorious black sites sacred prisons run
by the c.i.a majid khan a suburban
baltimore high school graduate who
became an al-qaeda courier and was
captured in pakistan testified for more
than two hours in front of a military
court at guantanamo he described in
graphic detail the violence sexual abuse
and humiliation he says the cia
interrogators inflicted on him he said
he was often tortured in a dark room
stripped naked and shackled the more i
cooperated he said the more i was
tortured
to get a better understanding of the
significance of all this we're joined by
karen greenberg who is the director of
the center on national security at
fordham university school of law and
mark demba who's a professor of law at
seton hall university who also
represents two detainees currently held
at guantanamo mr denbar let me start
with you what is the significance of
majid khan's testimony about the torture
that he suffered
well
it's the first time anybody has publicly
heard a description of the torture
i mean so that itself is a breakthrough
you know the beginning the word torture
was forbidden to be used in court and
then it was never supposed to be seen
this is a huge breakthrough
my client has sent out drawings of the
torture and that got a fair amount of
attention but what maja did showing the
human being the face of it describing
what it was like was in fact just
shaking for everybody including the jury
and karen greenberg were you surprised
by any of his testimony about the
details of what he went through
we've seen books written by detainees
we've seen movies
so i wasn't surprised by the details of
it so much as by the tone of this is
what happened to me as a person
struggling with the death of my mother
struggling with what i'd done wrong with
al qaeda so his his sense of genuine
sense of remorse the vulnerability the
horror of the torture that he went
through so that is what surprised me
and professor denvale had quite an
impact on the military jury
well that's what this most remarkable
thing of all
to actually have a jury send a note to
the court
asking for in a sense clemency or at
least some sort of adjustment
recognition of his pain
is quite a staggering thing in fact i
think that will change the debate for
the future i don't think the prosecution
can be confident that when it puts on
witnesses who've been tortured the jury
will be appreciative of the
prosecution's position i mean i think
lots of evidence is now going to be
inadmissible once this story comes out
after all almost all their evidence is
derived from torture similar to homages
so what happens to those detainees if
they can't use the evidence and they
don't want to release them are they
still in a legal limbo forever
well uh the key words are forever right
um clearly they're in a legal limbo and
they always have been i think lots of
changes are happening at guantanamo i
don't think it's an accident that
lawyers are now
moving to have their clients released
because the war in afghanistan is over
and the war with al al-qaeda has been
one decade ago so i think that the
courts are going to start approving
people for release at least those not
charged by military commission and karen
greenberg what is the effort now to shut
down guantanamo uh two different
administrations have pledged to do that
it still hasn't happened what stands in
the way of that
well i i agree with mark i think the
movement towards closing guantanamo
is is starting to happen what stands in
the way is is actually the uh fact of
torture what stands in the way is the
fact that it's almost impossible to
mount these cases because the government
has claimed under uh under state secrets
that much can't be revealed and because
um evidence that is the result of
torture cannot be used in a court
proceeding and so as a result you've had
proceedings that haven't really been
able to get to the trial stage and um i
think that as torture comes into the
conversation inside the courtroom which
is what has happened here it is going to
change what's allowable and change what
happens professor dembele as you were
saying the word torture was sort of
banned by many administrations
at major news networks they couldn't use
the word a big debate about it now even
supreme court justices are just simply
saying it's torture right the guantanamo
now stands for detaining people without
charge who were tortured a few are being
charged but guantanamo they recognized
the senate select committee recognized
america and tortured at least 119 people
many of them have been through
guantanamo and been released and i think
the politics of it is changing so fast i
don't think the american people really
care
about keeping these people locked in
guantanamo and i think a president who's
ended the war in afghanistan
is probably well positioned to be able
to close guantanamo so i'm quite
optimistic for both of my clients i just
want to focus on one thing that
professor dembo said which is that you
know president
president obama got way ahead of his
skis he on his second day of his
presidency i'm going to close guantanamo
and we then provide
the process whereby guantanamo will be
closed
no later than one year from now
biden isn't doing that he's going about
this in a very kind of quieter
procedural way
and um so we don't actually know what
arrangements are being made or what will
be made but seven uh detainees have been
cleared for release since he took office
i hope more are in the cadre of folks
that can be
cleared for release that aren't being
held before military commissions well
professor dembele finally your client
abu zubaydah if he were to be released
would he pose a threat to the united
states is he so angry about what
happened that he would try to seek some
sort of revenge
no
absolutely not first of all he never was
considered america the enemy he never
attacked america never proposed doing it
so he's in there because they made a
mistake by the cia but having recognized
that that probably doesn't distinguish
him for many people in there but you
know the point that i think we really
need to make is how
angry the detainees are not
you know nobody in guantanamo or
anywhere else can live with anger and
rage for 20 years if they'd been
prosecuted in new york in 2008
we wouldn't even be talking about any of
this they'd been prosecuted tried
perhaps sentenced appealed and all of
those things and it would be over
instead we're stuck in this process
that's an embarrassment to american
legal system for many many reasons
professors karen greenberg and mark
dembele thank you so much for being with
us here tonight
okay my pleasure thank you
coming up next this week's winners and
losers in the media see if you agree
with what the editors of mediaite have
to say about john oliver
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media as chosen by the
editors of meteorite and we're joined by
aidan mclaughlin who is the
editor-in-chief of mediaite which like
the long crime trial network is part of
the dan abrams media empire and aiden
was chosen for your winner this week
john oliver for his take on homelessness
but the very first step here is a
collective change of perceptions
basically we need to stop being dicks
and assuming that the unhoused are a
collection of drug addicts criminals
who've chosen this life for themselves
instead of people suffering the
inevitable consequences of gutted social
programs and a nationwide divestment
from affordable housing aiden pretty
serious talk for a comedian
that's right you know john oliver does
this he's obviously a very funny
comedian but on his hbo show which airs
on sunday nights he'll often do deep
dives into pretty serious and meaty
policy uh stuff uh this week was the
homelessness crisis in the united states
which i thought did a really good job of
breaking down not just the obvious
details of the crisis but also how we
perceive the homeless and how media
covers them um i think one thing that
gets lost in this debate about
homelessness and the crisis in the
united states um is that we often
descend into sort of culture war uh
fights about this um you know fox news
for example will cover homelessness as
this sort of evil plague on cities like
san francisco a plague that exists
because of feeble liberal governance um
so i think taking a step back and
looking at the crisis and trying to
figure out a way that we can address it
whilst treating homelessness like a
problem for the people that are actually
suffering for it uh is something that's
worth doing and that's something that
john oliver really drilled home
so i thought it was a great uh really
great episode of his show on sunday
night in aidan for the loser you chose
the white house correspondent for the
news max network tell us about emerald
robinson
that's right so emerald robinson is the
white house correspondent for newsmax um
she claimed on twitter uh this week in a
tweet that has now since been removed um
that vaccines contain some sort of
satanic tracker um called luciferase
and it's this really dumb conspiracy
theory that we traced back um it's been
bouncing around the internet for months
reuters actually fact checked it a few
months ago and found that none of the
vaccines contain uh luciferase which is
a chemical compound and not a satanic
tracker um it's not surprising that
robinson would tweet something like this
she's been a pretty consistent uh
vaccine conspiracy theorist what is
surprising about this story is that
newsmax issued two lengthy statements
condemning her and calling her claims
false um so it's not a good day for any
news person when their own network is
issuing multiple statements uh rejecting
their claims is utterly false um she has
now also been suspended from twitter
that just happened about an hour ago um
so it has continued to be a bad week for
emerald robinson and very quickly is she
still employed as the white house
correspondent for newsmax as far as i
know she's still at newsmax off twitter
but still at newsmax all right well
fascinating what a conspiracy theory to
spin and then get rebuked by your own
network aidan mclaughlin thank you so
much for joining us tonight
and that's our program tonight thank you
all for joining us and thanks for a
great team here at the law and crime
network for getting us on the air and
getting us off the air every single week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you